WE LOVE HIM FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AMERICA, NOT
FOR HIS SUPPORT TO PUTIN.
>> Tucker: GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST GLOBAL
WARMING SEEMS TO HAVE GONE BUST
IT STARTED AS AN EFFORT TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT IT IS
NOT THAT ANYMORE.
DETAILING HOW THE MOVEMENT HAS
BEEN HIJACKED BY OBSESSIONS WITH
RACE AND GENDER, WORRIES ABOUT
CARBON AND RISING SEA LEVELS
HAVE TURNED INTO SPEECHES ABOUT
FIGHTING MISOGYNY AND SO-CALLED
CLIMATE JUSTICE WHATEVER THAT
IS.
STEVEN HAYWARD JOINS US TO
EXPLAIN.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, ISN'T IT AMAZING
HOW EVERYTHING SEEMS TO GET
REDUCED TO RACE AND JUSTICE
THESE DAYS?
>> Tucker: IT'S ESPECIALLY
AMAZING WHEN TOPICS THAT HAVE NO
CONCEIVABLE CONNECTION GET
PULLED IN, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> THE POINT OF THE ARTICLE IS
SIMPLE.
MOST ISSUES GO THROUGH THESE
LONG CYCLES LOTS OF EARLY
INTERESTS, THE PRESS GETS ONTO
IT, A FLURRY OF POLITICAL
ACTIVITY, POLICIES ARE MADE,
THEN WE START HAVING
CONSIDERATION TRADE-OFFS.
IF THAT'S BEEN GOING ON WITH
GLOBAL WARMING FOR SEVERAL YEARS
GLOBAL WARMING FOR SEVERAL YEAR
YEARS.
IT'S REALLY EXPENSIVE TO DO WHAT
A LOT OF THE CLIMATISTAS WANT US
TO DO.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER OF GENDER
AND CLIMATE JUSTICE, THAT'S
JUMPING THE SHARK.
PUBLIC OPINION SURVEYS SHOWED
DECLINING PUBLIC INTEREST IN THE
DARN THING.
>> Tucker: IT'S A BOUTIQUE
ISSUE FOR RICH PEOPLE BUT IT'S
ALSO CONFUSING.
EVEN IF YOU THINK THAT CLIMATE
JUSTICE IS REAL OR IF YOU CAN
EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS I'VE NEVER
MET ANYONE WHO CAN OR YOU THINK
GENDER EQUALITY IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS, WHAT DOES THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH SCIENCE?
THAT'S NOT SCIENCE, IS IT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID
IN THE ARTICLE.
I'M NOT QUESTIONING ANY OF THE
CONSENSUS ABOUT CLIMATE SCIENCE
I'M SAYING IS A POLITICAL POLICY
MATTER, IT'S RUN ITS COURSE.
YOU SHOULD'VE SEEN MY TWITTER
FEED A BLOWUP.
APPARENTLY IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
CALL SOMEONE A CLIMATE DENIER AT
ALL, I'M GETTING CALLED A WHITE
MALE SUPREMACIST WHICH IS A GOOD
SIGN THAT YOU'VE RUN OUT OF
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE ISSUE
ITSELF.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T APPROACH
BEING AN ARGUMENT, IT'S A PRIMAL
SCREAM.
YOU WERE AT A BERKELEY HOW ARE
YOU ALLOWED TO SAY THIS AT
BERKELEY?
AND GOOD FOR YOU FOR BEING THERE
AND GOOD FOR YOU FOR BEING THER
THERE.
>> I'M LIKE THAT CIVIL WAR ERA
GENERAL WHO SAID I LIKE TO FIGHT
SURROUNDED, I THINK THAT
MIGHT'VE BEEN GENERAL CUSTER.
TWO THINGS THAT YOU AND YOUR
AUDIENCE SHOULD KNOW AND BE
ENCOURAGED BY A LITTLE BIT.
ONE IS WE OUGHT TO MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN
OLD-FASHIONED LIBERALS WHO
DOMINATED UNIVERSITIES FOR
DECADES, THAT'S NOT A NEWS STORY
INCREASINGLY THE UNIVERSITIES
ARE BEING DOMINATED BY MUCH MORE
RADICAL PROGRESSIVE LEFT THAT AS
WE KNOW TURN TO VIOLENCE TO GET
THEIR WAY.
A LOT OF THE OLD-FASHIONED
LIBERALS UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
CRISIS FOR THE UNIVERSITIES AND
A LOT OF THEM ARE STARTING TO
SAY, I THINK YOU WANT TO GIVE
PROPS TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ACADEMICS AT BERKELEY WHO SAID
WE HAVE A PROBLEM AND WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME MORE CONSERVATIVE
VOICES ON OUR FACULTY AND ON OUR
CAMPUS.
HE REACHED OUT TO BE A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AND INVITED ME TO COME
AND I'M GLAD TO BE THERE, I'M
HAVING A GREAT TIME AND I GET
ALONG WITH MOST OF THE LIBERALS
ON THE CAMPUS JUST FINE AND THE
RADICALS WANT TO GAUGE ME AT
ALL.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE
DISTINCTION, IF LIBERALISM IS A
CONCERN FOR CIVIL LIBERTIES, A
BELIEF IN ACTUAL DIVERSITY THAT
I'M A LIBERAL AND PROUD TO BE
ONE.
THERE AREN'T MANY LEFT I'M GLAD